j'avoue qu'il me met pas à l'aise
laurent wauquiez est un homme qui est
hérité d'une circonscription celle de
jacques barrot jeanne par faire voir
l'européen fervente européen vice
président la commission européenne
inquiète un grand européen et je trouve
que le rock est à oublier ça ces
propositions pour pratiquement sortir la
commission du jeu on faire le
secrétariat du conseil des ministres
pour des formes de n'ont pas de
protection mais de protectionnisme ce
nationalisme exacerbé sera menée sans
arrêt le pays a ses racines culturelles
sous entendu la chrétienne tout ça non
ne me paraît pas conforme au génie
français après les militants des
républicains choisiront mais je connais
cet homme il est talentueux
assurément intelligent très intelligent
mais sa détermination me paraît parfois
sans limite
et quand on touche aux valeurs on touche
aussi à ce qui fait l'âme française
il ya une part et de l'âme certaines de
ces propositions touchent l'âme
française abîme l'âme française